foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
attain successful single cell sequencing
results with the latest cell and nuclei
isolation workflows
this webinar is a part of the 10th
Annual genetics virtual week
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
miltony biotech for more information
about miltony biotech please go to
miltonybiotech.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find the live chat
located at the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present
Alina Steinbach product manager for flow
sorting at miltony biotech and Karina
Emory product manager for sample
preparation also at miltony biotech for
a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Alina and Karina you
may now begin your presentation
so getting quality single cell
sequencing data really starts with your
example
um so
your sample has to meet certain pre-west
prerequisites in order to generate
reliable results you need a debris free
single cell suspension with the
viability ideally above 90 percent
next to the prerequisites for the sample
there are also requirements through the
preparation method of your example it
should be fast and avoid changes in the
gene expression pattern when possible
and you want to maintain the cellular
composition of your sample preparing
cells without introducing bias is a
tough undertaking and even when
preparing pbmcs from blood samples you
already stress the cells in light of
regulate stress Kings this becomes even
more complex when isolating cells or
nuclei from complex tissues so in the
end whenever preparing samples for
single cell genomics you will most
likely introduce some kind of bias that
you should be aware of
um so
Let's uh introduce miltani's workflow
solutions to help you achieve a sample
that makes all the requirements in order
to get generate reliable genomics data
when you work with solid tissue
um um so sorry yeah so here's our
workflow uh when you work with uh solid
tissue you have to start with tissue
dissociation and actually even before
that you might have to store your tissue
for some time
um if you're working with blood products
of course you don't need to dissociate
your tissue
um but you do need to clean your sample
um so cleaning your sample refers to
removing debris or large Aggregates
um after that you have the optional step
of isolating target cells and then
finally you have to do your Excel
analysis or QC before proceeding onto
your single cell analysis experiment
um so let's look at the first step here
which is tissue storage
um so it's not often possible to begin
processing tissue for your single cell
sequencing immediately after the tissue
was harvested for long-term storage
freezing and storing samples at minus 80
or in liquid nitrogen is one option
however you should be aware that when
snap Frozen or Frozen very quickly
without a cryoprotectant your tissue
will lose the ability to isolate cells
so you'll have to do the analysis on the
nuclei
slow freezing with the cryo protectant
like DMSO will allow you to recover by
viable cells but you should expect
decreased viability we recommend working
with fresh samples whenever possible
which is why we developed the max tissue
storage solution to maintain cell
viability in cellular composition of
fresh tissue stored at four degrees for
up to 48 hours
our tissue storage solution has been
validated to prevent necrosis and
apoptosis in maintain cellular
composition and gene expression patterns
to demonstrate this we dissociated Mouse
tumors either immediately after
dissection or after storage in the
tissue storage solution for either 24
hours or 48 hours at 4 degrees
we then used flow cytometry to measure
viability and as you can see in the
graph on the left we found no
substantial differences in viability
between the fresh ink stored tissue we
also assessed gene expression in the
fresh versus stored tissue looking for
differentially expressed things and
stress and toxicity Pathways and as you
can see we did not find any upregulation
in the stress genes after 24 or 48 Hours
of storage compared to Freshly dissected
tissue we don't have the data shown here
but we also have data to demonstrate
that we are not authoring cell type
composition after storage for up to 24
or 48 hours
so after historic the next step in the
workflow is going to be our tissue
dissociation
here you have multiple options you can
dissociate tissue either with enzymes at
37 degrees or you can try using a cold
adapted enzyme at four degrees you can
also go without enzymes and you can also
go without enzymes and rely purely on
mechanical force or you can use an
enzyme free message for nuclei
extraction
each method has its pros and cons which
have been discussed in the literature
cold adapted Protocols are of interest
to reduce the risk of gene expression
alterations we at milteni have
historically focused on on optimizing an
enzymatic dissociation of tissues into
single cells at 37 degrees because we
have filmed that this gives the highest
cell viability in yield while preserving
cellular composition however we know
that for some genomic applications
nuclei are the starting material in that
only nuclei can be obtained from some
tissue including snap Frozen tissues for
these reasons we release the nuclear
extraction buffer for tissue that just
came out in April and which we will
introduce shortly
um first let's start with tissue
dissociation into single cell
suspensions
well penny has developed the gentlemax
technology through the dissociation of
tissues into single cell suspensions the
genomax system combines mechanical
disruption with enzymatic digestion
which enables both processing time and
the amount of mechanical force to be
minimized resulting in the fastest most
gentle treatment of cells possible
questions some protocols use solely
enzyme digestion Which is less
sufficient compared with the genomics as
you can seeing this graph where a
customer compared a manual protocol for
lamina appropriate digestion with the
respective gentlemax protocol and found
a much higher yield of t-reg cells when
using the general Max
sole enzymes cannot reach areas within
the tissue making this method less
effective and elongating the incubation
time Magento Max constantly disrupts the
tissue and therefore enzymes can
efficiently be or can effectively reach
all areas of the tissue
on the other hand other protocols May
opt to do the mechanical dissociation
without any enzymatic digestion we need
demonstrating this here by dissociating
tumors either with or without using the
enzymes in our tumor dissociation kit as
you can see by using the enzymes in the
tumor dissociation kit we were able to
increase the yield of activated T cells
by over three-fold so here in the top
panel you can see we're getting
um in multiple Rec
um in multiple T cell types uh yield of
about 50 percent of our sample whereas
if we did not use a tumor dissociation
kit we were getting yields in the 9 to
15 percent range of our sample
so by combining mechanical disruption
and enzymatic digestion enzymes
concentrations and incubation times can
be reduced to a minimum which is also
true for mechanical stress because
enzymes soften the tissue by digesting
connective tissue and adhesion molecules
furthermore this can be done in a fully
automated walk away fashion in the
process and you can process up to eight
samples at a time this means you can
also reduce Hands-On time and decrease
variability as a result of tissue
processing
furthermore the general Max technology
has been shown to be compatible Upstream
of connect genomics products
to further enable reproducibility we
have developed over 20 tissue-specific
dissociation kicks with highly purified
enzymes with known activity levels in
lot to lock consistency for several of
our kicks we provide lists of preserved
epitopes which will be important for
experiments using feature bar coding
such as site seek by combining these
kicks with over 40 predefined programs
on digital Max instrument you can
reliably attain high yields of viable
cells Time After Time
as mentioned before some tissues such as
snap Frozen tissues cannot you cannot
isolate cells from snap Frozen tissues
the only option here is to extract the
nuclei instead moreover some genomic
applications require nuclei as a
starting material and for this reason we
recently recently released the nuclei
extraction buffer that can be used in
combination with the gentlemax
instruments and C Tunes
so here's our nuclei extraction workflow
you can start with up to 200 milligrams
of tissue
um that's either fresh or frozen and
then you drop that tissue into a pretty
chilled C tube filled with filled nuclei
extraction buffer the C tube has been
closed and placed onto the general Max
instrument where tissue lysis and
homogenization is completed in only
seven minutes moreover up to eight
samples can be processed in parallel
then the nuclei suspension is washed and
filtered and optionally further cleaned
by sorting on the max Quant title prior
to a single nuclei analysis
the nuclei extraction buffer can be used
for virtually any tissue including snaps
Frozen or OCT embedded tissues as well
as fresh tissue the graph on the right
shows the yield for both snaps Frozen
and fresh tissue from mouth Sprain and
tuner
the chart on the right shows the ring
values from RNA extracted from nuclei
suspensions from various tissues after
being processed with or without the
um sorry after being processed with our
nuclei extraction workflow this buffer
has been validated for RNA analysis and
if performing a taxi Downstream
additional permanentization steps may be
required after nuclei extraction
in the next step of the workflow
dissociating samples need to be cleaned
from unwanted material including cell
clumps stag cells red blood cells and
debris the same is true when working
with splug samples as we noted before
for nuclei suspension sample cleaning
can be performed by flow soaring but
first we will show you additional
message for cleaning up your Excel
suspension
it's important to filter cell
suspensions to remove large debris and
cell Aggregates that can clog the
microfluidics of single cell sequencing
instruments like the 10x chromium
milpenney offers filters in a variety of
mesh sizes our smart strainers are for
filtering larger volumes and
pre-separation filters are for smaller
volumes the filters can be stacked to
filter your cell suspensions through
decreasing pore sizes in a single step
smaller debris can be removed
efficiently and easily with our debris
removal solution it's ready to use
gradient solution that requires just to
10 minutes centrifugation step with full
break and full acceleration
depending on your sample type you may
have significant contamination from red
blood cells red blood cells have very
little RNA and will contribute to more
background noise rather than making
functional libraries so large amounts of
red blood cells in your sample can be
problematic one option is to remove your
bread blood cells is to use our lysis
solution which only requires a two
minute incubation time
arguably one of the most important steps
in Sample cleanup is maximizing your
viability for the best results viability
should exceed 90 percent this is because
Doug sells leak cellular RNA and this is
into the solution which can increase
your background noise and contaminate
other cells with non-endogenous
transcripts big cells also still contain
RNA and can make functional libraries
but obviously you don't want to analyze
those dead cells for even more when
there are a lot of dead cells in your
suspension it becomes difficult to
distinguish live from dead cells
um so we have a one solution for this
which is Our Deck cell removal kit it
provides a fast and easy option to
increase viability the kit consists of
magnetic micro beads that will bind to
dead cells the cell suspension is then
passed through a Max column sitting in a
magnet and the dead cells remain in the
column while the live cells throw flows
through and this is all completed in 25
minutes
to demonstrate the impact of sample
cleanup on single cell sequencing We
performed a joint study with 10x
genomics to analyze tumor samples after
each cleanup step
in condition a the cleanup is minimal we
just filtered through a 70 Micron smart
strainer to remove large cell Aggregates
and debris and this was from a variety
of we tried this on three different
types of mouse turmeric samples that we
dissociated on the general Max and our
tumor dissociation kit
for condition B we added in one more
cleanup step which was red blood cell
lysis using
um our red blood cell lysis solution
finally on condition C we also added deg
cell removal in some cases we found that
a single round of dead cell removal did
not yield the desired viability this can
happen when you're starting viability is
very low especially if your viability
starts below 50 percent it's very likely
you might need to go through two rounds
of dead cell removal to get up to a 90
viability so in these samples we added a
second round of dead cell removal and
this was called condition d
finally single cell RNA seek libraries
were prepared with the chromium single
cell 3 Prime V2 Library kit we then
analyze the data based on several
performance metrics
cell recovery yielded the most striking
differences between each cleanup
condition on the 10x system you can
Target anywhere from 100 to 10 000 cells
per Library we targeted 5 000 cells per
Library which was indicated on the
graphs by the dotted horizontal line
when you look across each tumor type and
replicate the number of cells recovered
increased with additional cleanup steps
in some samples the increase in sales
recovered was very dramatic going from
500 to a thousand cells when in
condition a where we just did filtering
to hitting the target of 5
000 cells after we added in red blood
cell lysis and one to two rounds of dead
cell removal
they're
poor fill recovery can have a
significant impact on the resulting data
as shown here the TC plots on the left
are from Mouse melanoma tumor samples
that were only filtered in the blocks on
the right were from samples that got the
complete cleanup workflow including deg
cell removal and you can see how this
how this poor cell recovery could really
impact your Downstream analysis
hopefully I have convinced you that it
is important to have high viability
prior to single cell RNA sequencing but
miltoni is dead cell removal kit is not
your only option to increase viability
in your cell suspension so how do you
choose one that is the best for your
experiment
a recent publication compared several
Dex cell removal messing from Frozen
pvmcs it's common to see reduced
viability after cryopreservation
they tested four messings for dead cell
removal
um so the first was low spin washes the
second was miltenny's Doug cell removal
kit which is called column Base clean up
here
um the third was a competitor kit and
the fourth was a density based cleanup
step such as our debris removal solution
both the low spin washes and density
based cleanup rely on the fact that dead
cells tend to tend to be less dense than
live cells
in the graph on the left you can see
that milpenney's deck cell removal kit
was the only method to result in
significantly improved viability
in the graph on the right the white bars
show the fraction of cells that were
lost after each method all deg cell
removal methods will result in some cell
loss so it's important to consider what
is more important in your situation
increasing viability or having as many
cells as possible
for the next step in our workflow I'll
hand it over to Alina now who will
discuss Target cell isolation on the max
Quant title
hello everyone my name is Alina
Steinbach and I am a global product
manager for the maximum title at multini
biotech
I am really happy to discuss today with
you how you can optimize your genomics
workflow with gentle cell sorting
let's first discuss why cell sorting is
so important prior to sequencing
first we want to enrich our specific
Target cell populations and improve the
reads second we want to exclude dead
cells and debris in order to avoid cell
free DNA and RNA contaminations and
decrease the costs
however cell sorting is coming with some
challenges
first if the cell sorting technique is
Harsh dead cells might end up in the
sample and this could increase the costs
and also DNA and RNA contaminations in
the sample might result in background
harshness of the Sorting can also lead
to gene expression artifacts that lead
to false results
another challenge are timely delays due
to slow sample processing
and these could lead to gene expression
alterations again ending in false
results of your sequencing experiments
let's have a look at some exciting data
unsorted cells and sorted cells have
been compared in regards to their
background during this experiment it was
found out that unsorted cells had around
50 percent of reads actually being from
a cell the rest was due to high
background RNA sorted cells on the other
hand had about 97 percent of weeds
coming from the cell and only low
background RNA
showing how important cell sorting prior
to sequencing is
on the upcoming slides I want to discuss
how you can improve your sample quality
with using microchip-based gentle cell
sorting
the maximum title cell solder is a rear
benchtop cell Soldier due to its low
weight and small Dimensions it is
equipped with three lasers eight
fluorescent channels and two scattered
channels this provides full experimental
flexibility and the possibility of
multi-parameter cell sorting
if you are interested in more
information have a look on the website
the image brochure or the user manual
at the heart of the maxquan title there
is a microchip
let's have a look on the cartridge the
cells are inserted into the input
chamber
at the bottom there's a mixing propeller
keeping the cells at suspension at all
times
cells are sorted into the positive
collection chamber and the non-target
cells will all flow through to the
negative collection chamber
at the bottom of the cartridge there is
a microchip
on the right side we see this in more
detail cells are coming from the input
chamber into the channels of the
microchip they are crossing the laser
beams and if the system recognizes the
target cells a pulse will open a valve
and the cells will go to the positive
collection chamber all the non-target
cells will flow through to the negative
collecting chamber
here we can see the dimensions of the
microchip
see it is really small it's even smaller
than a match head
let's have a look at this in real life
the valve is opening and closing
here the green cells are sorted
the valve is really really fast it can
open up to 30 000 times per second
microchip-based cell sorting is a very
different principle comparatory
principle of droplet-based cell sorting
in conventional facts droplet surges the
process of cell sorting is Harsh
cells are under high pressure it can be
in the nozzle up to 70 PSI cells to get
decompressed and charged why they are
deflected from the Mac electromagnets
and they are also strong Shear forces
fax droplet solar systems are open there
are fluidics and tubings inside of the
instruments and these are leading to
aerosol production and contaminations
and also sample to sample carryover can
happen
if you think of clinical applications
this process of course a big problem
microchip-based cells I think is truly
gentle
sorting happens at low pressure and
cells do not get decompressed or charged
and they are only my two forces
starting in the closed and steroid
cartridge is safe there is no carry over
no contamination and also no aerosol
production
if you are interested in fast sorting at
a very good performance have a look at
our maxcon title cartridge HS
which is based on principle of inertial
focusing
let's have a look at how the cells are
arriving in a positive collection
chamber
for this an endoscope was inserted into
the positive collection chamber the
cartridge was loaded and the Sorting was
started
we can see here that the cells are
easily flying into the positive
collection chamber
another Advantage is that cells are
strongly concentrated during the Sorting
process because the valve is only
opening for the short time that the cell
needs to be sorted this can save you for
example a centrifugation step
operating the maximum title cell solder
is easy because it follows a plug and
play cartridge system
the sample has to be loaded into the
cartridge
the cartridge is scanned by a barcode
scanner
then it's loaded into the Mexican title
sorting is operator free and done by the
instrument itself
remove the sample and collect your cells
after the max container is done
overall you can save time with a maximum
title because it's 9 times less hands on
time compared to a conventional droplet
solar system
sorting of fragile cell types is
possible with the maximum title
neutrophils are known to be very
sensitive and getting activated by any
kind of stress
neutrals was sorted using the maximum
title cartridge HS
it was gated on c45 positive cells
they've revocated out
and the cells were sorted by cd60
positive and c45 load markers
the Purity was very good and above 98
percent
in a subsequent functional essay it
could be shown that these neutrophones
did not get activated a sign for
Activation is a cd62l down regulation
and the cd11b up regulation
this sign was not seen by the cell sort
with a Max con title a positive control
that got stimulated before showed these
signs of stress response
starting with the maximum title is
aerosol-free
here is a recent publication the
researchers use Dragon green beads and a
cyclics d impactor sampling cassette to
check for air results in the environment
the maxqueen title was compared to a
conventional droplet Soldier
while the droplet soldier produced many
aerosols during the process the max gun
title did not produce any aerosols
showing that it is possible to sort
biohazardous material with the maximum
title
a genomics workflow using the max core
title can look like the following
first single cell suspension has to be
performed for this one could use the
gentlemax system or for example cells
can be pre-enriched using the Automax
Pro then cells are sorted on a maximum
title and they are used for sequencing
afterwards
Cree at the UCI is working on Epco cells
he is interested in the diversity of the
cells and therefore he is performing
single cell genomics he is taking
mammary glands from mice
doing single cells pension and sorting
the cells via flow sorting and
afterwards he performs 10x genomics
interestingly he does a head-to-head
comparison of refax droplet solder and
the maximum title
first he observes that the cell types
and States between the cells sorted on
the title and the facts droplet sorter
are similar
however when he takes a closer look at
the data he sees that the cells from the
max quantitle
gave more Gene reads indicating a better
sample quality
he is also looking at the stress
response gene expression and he sees
that the cells sorted from the Mexican
title had a lower expression of stress
response genes
finally he also performs a functional
essay here he performs a sphere essay
and he observes that the cell sorted
with the microphone title from bigger
and more spheres in culture which is
indicating a higher cell functionality
all in all cell enrichment using the
maxcon title before sequencing improves
the sample quality and reads while
minimizing sequencing artifacts and
costs
last year there has been a very now on
exactly that topic if you are interested
have a look at it
nuclei sorting is getting more and more
important in the genomics field in order
to get rid of any components from the
cytosol that could lead to artifacts of
the analysis
so it was tried whether the Mexican
title could also sort nuclei
the nuclei was stained according to a
marker that is confidential this
experiment was done with a collaboration
partner
and according to staining with dappy
after the sword it was possible to reach
a purity of nuclei above 95 percent
I have to say that in this experiment
because it was a feasibility experiment
dappy was used as a marker but before
sequencing analysis we would recommend
to use 7aad to stain the nuclei
I want to show you some recent
Publications using the maximum title
priato sequencing
one example from covid-19 research is
coming from Patrick Wilson and his
colleagues they are working on B cell
subsets
another example from covid-19 research
is coming from Petra Baja and her
colleagues and they are interested in
the teaser memory
a study working on biomark
identification is using only
redentrocyte progenitor cells
and there is an example from non-human
Primate Research where they sorted
retinal cells
you can find more examples of
Publications here Alexander Johnson and
his colleagues are working on
endothelial cells in the pancreas if you
are more interested in this study there
has been a webinar on the topic you can
watch it on lab fruits
researchers from Italy are working on
conventional dendritic cells in covid-19
patients this is another great example
for centers of cell sorting and
biohazardous cell sorting from covid-19
patients
on the next two slides I want to give
you a bit more details about the
workflow that these researchers have
used
here is again the example from the
non-human primary research and they
sorted retinal cells from macaque which
are really sensitive cells
first they perform sample preparation
using the neural tissue dissociation kit
postnated neurons
and then with the singer sales pension
they go to the Mexican title and solve
the cells and afterwards they perform
sequencing
and her colleagues used to create
complex workflow and this is shown here
first there isolate pbmcs from Whole
blood originating from covid-19 patients
then they stimulate the cells using the
score to Pepto beta peptide pools and
they perform an enrichment according to
an essay called rapid art this is an
essay for the rapid antigen reactive T
Cell enrichment
after this they use these antigen
specific T cells that they have enriched
and thought according to the Dual
expression of cd69 and CD 154 on the
maximum title
with these cells they go for sequencing
so let's sum up all this information
microchip-based cell sorting is gentle
for the cells sorting in a closed
cartridge system office offers the
operator as well as sample safety
very sensitive cells such as neutrophils
or original cells can be sorted without
harming them
we have seen a presented example for
single cell sequencing and this showed
that sorting with a maximum title
pre-age sequencing improves the sample
quality and reads while minimizing
artifacts and costs
also nuclei can be sorted successfully
and with this I want to thank you for
your attention and we are happy to take
any of your questions
you know we now have time for some q a
so we're getting questions in here by
the chat so I'll go ahead and read it
out loud uh this first question is for
you you said that sorting was the title
is aerosol free has infectious material
being sorted on the title
yeah that's a really interesting
question thanks for that
um yes indeed infectious material has
been sorted on the title
especially in these current times with
the covid-19 pandemic we do have several
Labs that are sorting on patient
material on the maximum title
but there are also researchers who are
working on other viruses such as HIV for
example
um in addition to that other pathogens
have also been sorted on the maximum
title for example bacteria yeast and
also plasmodium parasites can be
soldered and after these thoughts there
have also been bio burn tests and they
could confirm that with the maxcon title
you can get your full sample containment
great
our next question here is uh looks like
it's going to be for me is milteni going
to make a kit for cold dissociation
um so yes this is definitely something
we are exploring right now so stay tuned
we'll be having even more solutions for
sample preparation specifically designed
for single cell sequencing
um in the future
okay
um so another question for uh Lena
um is it possible to sort rare cells
with the frequency below one percent on
the title
yes absolutely
um this is possible where cells can be
sorted on the maxcom title there are
many labs in the research but also in
the clinical fields are who are working
on antigen specific T cells antigen
specific B cells regulatory T cells and
also mscs from primary material and yeah
these cell types do have pretty low
frequencies
great
great so
um another question here can the debris
removal solution be used to remove dead
cells
um yeah that so there's a lot of
different ways that you can remove dead
cells from your tissue so the debris
removal solution is actually one way to
do that and it really depends on your
sample type whether you'd want to do for
example the debris removal solution the
dead cell removal kit or flow sorting is
also an option to remove dead cells
typically if you're using the debris
removal solution you also obviously have
a lot of debris to remove
um so if you have such a significant
amount of debris obviously you can um
clog the column for the deg cell removal
kit or you can clog your flow sorter so
in those cases your best bet is to
actually do that debris removal step
um and uh you might find that after
debris removal your viability is
actually adequate to move on to your
single cell sequencing
yeah
okay
um so I have another question for Elena
here uh the question is I have used flow
sorting before and my samples are very
dilute what dilution factor should I
expect if I use this sorter
yeah um in conventional droplet sorters
there's the sheets for it and um of
course this can dramatically increase
um the volume of your sorted sample and
yeah that might be the reason for the
dilution
um of course for Downstream applications
oftentimes you need a higher self and
concentration and centrifugation steps
that's often needed
um with the maximum title you do not
have fluidics in the instrument
everything is happening in this closed
on cartridge and therefore there is also
no sheath fluid
this yeah that leads to a higher cell
concentration of your target cells or
nuclei in your sword chamber
um and the reason is that the valve is
only opening for this really short time
where the cell is
um let through the
um positive collection chamber
um and yeah a really minor amount of
buffer will come through this so you
actually get a higher concentration of
cells so I'm not assorting on the max
container which can then yeah save you
for example centrifugation step
well that's a nice unexpected benefit
okay we have time for one more question
and it's our human are the human and
mouse tumor dissociation kicks
interchangeable
um so obviously we recommend the human
uh tumor dissociation kit for human
tumors uh this actually also includes
um patient derived xenografts that are
uh human tumor cells but grown in mice
uh so I
um wow I can't say that they won't work
on each other we do recommend um the
human tumor kit for human tumors and the
mouse tumor kit for Mouse tumors because
we do know that they have different
consistencies and they've been custom
tailored to each tumor type uh moreover
for both the human and mouse tumor
dissociation kicks we have an epitope
preservation list that is specific to
that kit so if you have certain epitopes
that you are very concerned about
preserving definitely check that list
and they're not exactly the same so you
might find
um one epitope is preserved in one kit
but maybe is slightly sensitive to the
end enzymes in the other kit
okay well that's all the time we have
for today thank you everyone for your
attention and tuning in thank you Elena
and Karina for your time today and your
important research before we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today I'd also like to thank our sponsor
miltony biotech for sponsoring today's
webinar
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until April 21st 2024. lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with any of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time get